why are you nervous you look beautiful
thank you
this is just a moment that i never
expected to have
morgan it is a big night for you and you
are sharing it with your mother how
special is this yeah i mean
i don't think i would be here for one
more one for her um
she threw me up on stage when i was
three years old so and a whole lot of
other things since then too but you know
she she gave me my initial start so
trying to show her some recognition now
you have a new song that is a tribute to
your mama what was your reaction when
you heard it for the first time the
first time i heard it i cried and of
course i was just
so humbled that he would do that for me
the second time i heard it
i said who's the girl from jefferson
city i think everybody had that question
morgan what's the answer to that she's
not around anymore but she stuck around
in the song
now in the lyrics you talk about your
mama worrying about you since 93 and
some bad decisions is she getting a
little bit more sleep these days seems
like it yeah i think i think i think so
you can ask her i guess you're sleeping
better now absolutely
how would you say
you have grown
in the last year
i think mostly i could attribute it to
being a dad you know
um
just seeing that i have another life
that i'm responsible for it kind of put
things into perspective for me so i just
didn't really have a choice and your son
is going to be two this summer yeah he
went to his first ever concert it was
yours he may have fallen asleep during
it but what did that mean to you to have
him there we started a little late it
was uh it was special you know i kind of
dressed him like me and everything we
kind of we did the whole little shebang
the cowboy boots the belts all of it
yeah it was it was awesome i he got to
spend it during the suite with my family
and with some other people i think jason
aldean was in there so he's just a
pretty good company for his first
concert what has been your favorite
thing about fatherhood
i think just getting him you know seeing
him get a personality
he's starting to get to where i i tell
him no and he just kind of
looks at me
i know it's about to get worse
but i like it uh now will you guys have
a big birthday party for him when he
turns to you yeah i gotta i gotta sit
down and and plan that in the next
couple weeks yeah okay how is
co-parenting going it's good too yeah i
can't i got no complaints it's uh
i was worried about it at first but i
feel very comfortable with it and i'm
really proud of the way me and his mom
handle it he looks just like you yeah he
does quite a bit especially if you
compare my baby pics to his yeah we look
a lot alike now tonight you're also
performing don't think jesus correct
don't think jesus am wasting on you i
get two songs tonight you get two songs
now don't think jesus is a very powerful
song it's about
seeking salvation and earning
forgiveness what do you want fans to
take away from this performance and this
moment from morgan wallin
yeah i think that uh
that kind of just speaks for my story
for the past you know 10 years but
especially the past couple you know i
feel like that song is really a big
representation of a lot of things that
i've been through and
and the attitude that i've approached it
with so i hope that comes across what
has gotten you through the last year in
particular
my family my friends and
just a really good team and you know my
kid
i've had a lot of a lot of really
positive things going on behind the
scenes you know that maybe weren't
necessarily brought to light but i've
been in a i've been been able to be in a
good place because of all that we've
seen a lot of public support from
artists like miranda and jason aldean
and eric church what has that support
meant to you yeah i mean you know
everybody tells you that they're your
friends when everything's good
um so it's it's uh it's really nice to
have people who who really mean that
morgan diddy tonight
talked about how he wanted you and
travis scott here saying he wanted to
un-cancel the cancelled what do you make
of that
you know i i've never uh ever spoke to
diddy but i would like to tell them
thank you tonight so it means a lot